We'll kick off today by starting with layered materials, so we'll cover how to use layered materials
We'll go about the old way that we may have approached layered materials in Unreal Engine
Then we'll talk about the Megascans approach and then also a new way
Which we'll take moving forward on our layered material journey. So layered materials. You've got the three different examples here
We've got the old way. We've got the Megascans way and we've got the new way and we'll talk about these
Different approaches as we go forward so layered materials are used in Unreal Engine to combine elements
That could be edited
So it's used to keep executions cleaner
You'll see in future examples that a node graphs can get very complex
When using previous ways, so just found finding ways to streamline that process
And we can we can use these
layered materials approaches for example
Snow on rock or moss on wood or anything where you want to kind of create some variation
Layered on top of an existing material and you can also make it face a certain direction
So with the snow on rock, for example, we can get it
So it just falls on the top of the rock and not anywhere else
So layered materials can be really powerful in that approach. So the old way was
Using multiple make material attributes and then also using material functions
We'll dig into the later
Megascans way and then also layered materials and blend materials and you can see two examples here where we've got
one with using other material expressions and then one without so
You can see that just just from this graph alone without using them
It creates unnecessary
Complexity is hard to read what exactly is going on and when you do use them
It's a much more streamlined approach to the information to highlight the old way briefly
Just you understand the process here. We're working with material functions and layered
Material functions. So this is specifically for layering
So the steps to do this would be to right-click in your content browser
You can go to the material section here and then select material function
You'd create a couple of material parameters
Which are scalar parameters or vector parameters and we'll load up an example here in a second
Just so you can see exactly what's going on
I would have some kind of material layer some kind of function input expression and then
Some network to define the material layer and then you'd have the function output into the final material
so we'll jump into the editor now just to show you the old way of doing things and
Here's an example of how we may have approached layered materials
Say we want some bark and we want some moss growing on the back. So we had
Our material functions here, which we just reference
So we've got a material function for wood and a material function for moss so you can dig into all these
Nodes if you'd like we're just in the back and it's called moss simple
Material we've got the the function here at wood
So whenever you see a material function like this, you can just click the search button here
So we'll go to search and we've got the material function, which is wood
so again
Consider amount of complexity going on. We'll close this wood material
We've also got the moss material here and we can just find that again
And that's kind of overview of how we may have approached
Moss
Close that down and then essentially we just layer blend
Which there'll be many to choose from we got the base material here, which is the wood or the back in our example
we got the top material, which is the moss and then we alpha it to keep the
Z axis up. So
Again, we just got a const here for the blend bias as well and a world align blend going into the material
Attributes property looking at a slightly more complex set up you can see the way
How we've made some kind of tiling snow here
So again, I'll dig into the editor show you exactly where this content is so you can dig into it yourself
but we're not going to spend too long looking at this approach because
There's also a newer way which would be better
But it just helps show you context about how you may have set up materials. So you understand how we got to the end result
So from the content package here, we were using the rock underscore SNW for snow
Underscore complex and so you can see the breakdown here again
You can dig into it in your own time got a few different maps going on
Here and then also we've got the material function which is snow covering this instance so you can find
all this content
Inside your content browser to really break down and dissect the material of exactly what is going on here
The next slide approach to talk about is the mega scans approach, which is a really nice straightforward process
It does a lot of the heavy lifting for you under the hood so you can get going with your assets, but essentially
Mega scans are selected from the the quixel bridge
So if you load up the quixel bridge, you can add these to your project
You can see the quixel bridge on the drop down here
If not, you can get quixel bridge from the marketplace
There's some good documentation online of how to get quixel bridge added to your project
So then you want to click the little icon here
Which is a quality pull down on the bottom right of the asset and then you can select what desired
Materials you would like for this mega scans
Asset, so just a quick note here that using this tool will require a material instance from the current bridge version
Set of materials so it may not work with old material instances
So if you're having any issues with the instancing of the material just make sure your your bridge version is is set correctly
And maybe then just restart the project and you should be good to go from there
Now, let's look at the new way to make
Material layers, so we first want to create a material layer
So you can just right-click in your content browser go to materials and select material layer
You can call it either grunge or something else
Whatever you'd like and this first one will be a bit of our noise kind of texture
So once it's made open it up and you'll see these three nodes on the right hand side here
Then we want to create a material layer
To make the make material attribute. So if you just right-click and say make material attributes
You'll get this box here
And then we also want to drag in an albedo which is our texture sample there and our normal
And any other texture items that you might want to make the material more visually dynamic
So once you have them connect them into the input attributes node like so and then save
This new material layer and then sticking with your grunge material
I just forget about this image on the right for now, but sticking with the grunge material you want to right-click
the diffuse texture
Convert that to a parameter call it diffuse right-click the normal
Convert that to a parameter call it norm or normal or something like this
And then that that means we can switch out the textures whenever we want on the fly rather than coming back into the main
material layer
So then save that grunge material and then create a new material layer
Which is similar to this image on the right hand side and then we can call that whatever you'd like based on
What its purpose is say it's a dirt or grass or grime something like this where we're going to create a new material layer
We want to repeat the first process. So we want to make material attributes
We want a diffuse and a normal and then this time we want an albedo tint
So you can hold down three and left-click to create this type of node here and then right-click
convert to parameter call it the albedo tint and then
plug that into a multiply of
the material attributes
So to show you exactly what we've got going on here. We've got our grunge layer, which is a texture sample
Here and then also the make material attributes and then we've also got our second layer
Which is our diffuse and normal going into the multiply like that. So we have tuned layers
Now we have the grunge and the layer tile
Now we want to create a master material to plug these into so you can just right-click in your content browser go to create material
and then
Whatever naming convention you use you could call it
master
Material or you could name it something else
But in the master material, we want to right-click and type in material attributes layers
And that will give us this box that you can see in this image here
Now before you plug anything in what you can do is you can go to the details panel and
You'll see a little tick box there called use material attributes. And if you click that
That will automatically connect everything up. So it'll condense the master material
Attributes here and go straight into the material attributes layer. So this will be your master material setup
So once it looks like that you can save and close
So then in your master material now the node that you just created the material attributes layer node
You can select that and drop down these layers
So in the first layer, you could add the layer tile for example in the background
You could add that grunge layer that you created. So we've still not made our blend asset
Yep, we'll make that in a second. But that's what your material expression should look like
So I'll just jump back into my editor and then in this master material
I'll select my material attributes layers and then here are the layers
That we just want to be selecting here
So you've got your your background layer asset and your layer 2 asset
And then once our material layers are assigned in our master
We now want to make our blend material that you just saw so go back to your content browser
we want to make another
Material layer blend and load this into the blend asset slot. So this is going to be
Material, so I will jump into editor and show you this now
So if you just right-click in some empty space go to materials
And then you want to create a layer blend this time
So material layer blend and then we've just called this matte blend here, but you can essentially see this type of blended
Material setup that you need if you ever looking for these these are called the the function
inputs, so if you just right-click function input, you can see that there and then that would be
Material attributes type of leave. Yeah material attributes. So if ever you need to create those
That's how you create that but essentially we do want to blend these two attributes
Over the alpha which is another parameter into this output materials attributes
So as we can see, we keep the node structure for this simple
We just want to add the alpha condition just by right-clicking
To create a scalar prompter. You can actually use the s hotkey here
So you can S and left-click and you can create a parameter with a name there
You just want to call this alpha and then this is just the simple blend that we want to use
So now we can go back to the master material and connect the material attributes layer
To this blend. So as you saw before this blend node material here
We just want to put our blend material into there
And now we can make an instance of this master material
So you can right-click on the material and create a new instance based on that
So now we have an alpha slot in the instance that we can use to turn on and manipulate the layer
So let's just jump in the editor to show that now
So we can just go to that master material that we created a right-click create new material instance
Call this whatever you would like
Install one or anything like that and you'll see that now we have our layers here where you'll see the background layer grunge
And you've got the layer tile and also the blend assets
And so with the original blend material that we created with the alpha
We can turn it on and off and manipulate that layer in the parameters tab
So using that existing blend asset, we have the alpha 0 to 1 and we can manipulate that
But we want some more complex blending
Going on in our material to create a little bit more of the desired outcome that we want
So we're layering up these effects. So we want to create another layer blend material
So just right-click materials go to your layer blend same as we did before and then this this time
We want an alpha in place to get more realistic
Something to control the effect instead of the overall fade in and out
So to do this will create
this type of material setup, so
You'll you'll now be able to see that the intensity will replace the alpha control
So in the master material attribute layer node, we can adjust these as needed
We'll also need to create new layers
Quickly with established layers all ones we built to switch them in and out. So this is our current
Attribute layer node you can see that we've got a texture sample just grabbing from the green channel
We've got a multiply into a scalar called intensity again. You can just s and left-click there
We've got a contrast one, which is a power
So we go from the multiplier to the power and then into the exponent there to get the contrast
We clump the two values and then the rest is similar to how you had created before
So this is our now new blend material that we're plugged into this master material
And it means that we have more control over this effect
So we can also create a new layers quickly by adding new layers up here
Once you've got the establishing layers, you can switch them out with this plus button
So it speeds up the process of how we want to combine and mix these effects
So pro tip here is you want to be careful not to make too many layers as you it will cause the materials
complexity to grow pick and choose the best parts and
maybe create different master materials based on what you need the outcome to be if you want to
Have lots of customizable options. So the system makes things cleaner, but not necessarily lighter and
Here is the documentation if you want to first of all go into the old way of creating material layers
We've got the documentation there, but also the new way material layers our approach. It's a little bit of a context switch in your head
It'll take a bit of trial and error
But hopefully that was just a good starting point for you to dig into using material layers inside of Unreal Engine